why haven't we seen more of you two
together it's a pairing it really is
it's a match made in heaven
no Jackie Chan yes Jeff Chan yeah
I haven't done that once I'm very good
my hands I'm going Jackie Chan I'm not
doing it because is it true that
everyone just goes Jackie Chan yeah I
really hate that yeah whatever I going
on you're of America especially the
father bear children yeah why why nobody
see Robert DeNiro there's a Robert De
Niro Wow
Dustin Hoffman one day one day I hope
people wow that's a Jackie Chan I'm
trying I'm trying to respect myself
you just come from the the Cannes Film
Festival yeah
do you enjoy things like that are they
fun or is it just that business the
whole thing but those big events the
coral the you know potatoes red carpet
things and do you enjoy them do you like
doing no no I can't do any of that I'm
really calm but I've seen you I did go
well have you want a red carpet I don't
think so
no have you see you show up at things
not much to be honest but you've done
posh things you you've mixed with what
you've met the Queen haven't you I have
met the Queen yes I have a queen Adam I
think it was a one of those receptions
for people in the arts you should have
been there yeah I'm well you know what I
was amazed at with the Queen she's very
tiny which is something for me today cuz
I'm quite short and she moves as if on
rollerblades that there's no actual
walking see I don't know what's going on
under there hands to where you are the
group where you are for a start you have
to you have to tussle with that whole
idea of will you curtsy wait your coats
will you curtsy and I decided before no
look curtseying it's no I'm not going to
bow down before right I'm not going to
and then immediately you do
you revolting and then of me I mean and
then and then the Queen says a smoke
there was a group of that four of us
around her and she says a very small
thing you know so are you enjoying the
evening and everybody goes like this
like eager to please don't want to be
beheaded or something I'm sure my
singlet she's a great comedian or
something
in Hong Kong I remember and a long long
time ago my my English so bad in that
time I remember when Queen raised your
hand you use your hand otherwise you're
standing here blah blah blah blah blah
and you write what your royal highness
yes yeah yeah I didn't have the room
you're right highness your highness
Dennis what we playing around
Oh Queens come in please come in here
then I see the Queen stop stop stop
so quick okay then when she come with
your area immediately
you immediately bow
she stands still standing there people
Oh
she keep talking to me my hat is empty
she talking about
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
of course I'm so happy just tending here
more than like a three minute five
minutes but I just don't come with me
talk to me anymore
answer back I'm sorry did the Queen go
Chucky jack
[Applause]
[Music]
you